[Music]
like bring us what's going on we hear
boxing right now Mike Tyson was in
Britain and man Evan next guest men in
this greater accomplished dude one of
our good buddies he's here a lot
Fabricio Werdum hey brother hey it's
awesome to have you man everything is
good and I think before you guys invite
me
oh man of course anytime dude any day
talk about you know I'm in training a
lot for my next fight you know I trained
a good training yeah yes for sure I have
a fight you know that a combat the
combat jiu-jitsu MIT you like for
shortages grappling and the one when the
ground the bitch-slap you know yes you
know this is good what a fight versus a
Gordon Ryan he's the the best grappling
the warden in this moment no oh wow yes
Fabrice 22nd that's right yes but you're
here man because you just saved a young
teenagers life how did you know he was
drowning did you see a man yes man this
I just took my fam for that because I'm
living in the beach you know Redondo
Beach and I'm in there I just go to the
beach normally usually I go just go to
the the same place all the time same
place but this time go different place
you know and it's not too far than my
normally place you know and I just take
my family everything is good picnic in
the beach a lot of food everything is
good and the one I saw the garden life
coming and this siren you know that is
where what happened and the hiko
and they say well what happened here
nothing I don't see nothing when he
stopped in the front mind and on the
front boom I see when I look in the
ocean there two guys in inside yo you
know help the growth is growing a lot
but a lot but very far when I saw just
having one guy guard life just one when
I saw this I say I have to help my I say
to my wife and I she said she's scared
she hold me like a DS you know she hold
me I see I can't boom I take my t-shirt
off and they go running to the guy you
know I mean who are you wanna help and
he say please please and I just hit a
cat the board the big board you know
yeah and he go inside and I look at
there and I saw it how could the fat
full-floor know hello - yes I saw these
they take a DS I put in my chest wound
up a watch yes there's an a running boom
boom while running I start to swim and I
saw the girl like at the iceman to grow
the little girl oh man I'm very I mean
scared to my the girl
yeah grow and the moral one yes and I'm
very scared Mike my my heart that I had
the fight it's no problem I go to the
fight is okay but this situation my
heart like a very hard you know and I
saw the grow help very close my you know
but I say to the guy I say to the garden
life a man you take it to grow and they
take the guy because the guys later meal
in the back you know and that he he
drink a lot of Worman when I take him
here like a very lazy you know he's like
a very tired he felt exhausted yes yes
very houses and he can talking and just
take him they just say man taking oh no
problem i I take you and then I take him
I give it a float for him and I just I
just walked at the left side and I start
to walk and he just very I'm just taking
very hard you know and go to the the car
and the guys have a to more guarded life
in coming and they say no you guys need
more help in the Gateway don't think
appreciate Baba behind the guys and then
later guys coming again say thank you
and then this very hard job man this is
very hard to imagine just for one day
for me and that these guys every day's
work these you know every day yeah and
I'm very I'm Finn
very well you know I'm feeling like
later I received in my Instagram a mic
about like a 5,000 man said a lot of
masters mallanna messes cause my wife
sent film later
my wife's film little bit you know yeah
we could bring it up I got the video
right yeah yeah uh yes yeah you have
here okay check this - boom grow yes oh
wow
she screen a lot she cry a lot a man
before Mike I mean how about the
sweating you know it's a very cold in
the beach but when I go in I know
feeling the natural that means zero what
a very cold but I don't feeling nothing
just go I just want to save this guy
that the guys you know this is my my
goal this moment you know and I want
that thing one of my wife say she hold
me and I she when I am go but she's
scared you know she's scared my
daughter's inside my little daughter
have a fourteen years old I started to
cry my other world Lord - you know and
ice is very hard situation and I imagine
it and the cops you know the the garden
life in every day the guys did them and
every day this is guys I'm congratulate
for all the guys man well it's sort of
the universe brought you to that yes I
believe you Mike I believe you know why
I normally just go to the same place all
the time in front of my home poom poom
all the time you know this Sunday I go
to the picnic
okay go there and they just start there
but different place you know different
place completely I parked my car
different place I run into the beach
different place you know everything is
different this time everything man I
think that God put me there for sure I
believe that no I believe yes that's
crazy dude yeah I'm feeling in very very
well man you know just for saved one
life and very good that I can you know
yes give me a lot of motivation for
training Schumann yeah he has everything
change you know what my mind changed
humans give you a lot of
yes yes yes well knowing you just a
little that I've known you man it
doesn't surprise me at all
you know these they were like yeah did
you hear Fabricio saved somebody the
other day and I'm like oh that sounds
pretty normal for Fabrice amazing Mike
is very quickly decision you know as a
1-second go or not go you know and maybe
I'm a different place my normally plays
I go and I saw the card too far I don't
know what me going you know but the in
the front - in the front boom is there I
saw the kids
wow how yeah you know the decisions I
kept going up you know it's very quick
like a 1 second you have it to DC's you
know because the one second to second is
a lot of time for this guy there yeah
two of them - yes you basically you just
saw it and made a decision you were
going right away
boom I just take my t-shirt off moving
that running very fast to the guy you
know yeah and they say you wanna help
you say yeah for sure please do but I
saw his face like hey he go - you wanna
go you know yes man it's like a
different different moment in my life
for sure and did you grow up swimming or
do you are you a good swimmer
no I'm not like a very good no I'm
swimming for short but not like a
professional you know yeah yes but I'm
swimming for sure yes I like it swimming
- you do
yes yes yes so you weren't worried about
the conditions of the ocean yeah as far
as getting out seven I think you said it
was like 70 meters out yes yes so that's
a pretty far way out yes for you to just
say I'm gonna go haul ass out there and
grab these we have to pull somebody and
then I'm gonna bring this person back
this I have on my mind shoe I take a Sun
thing you know when I saw he take it the
born I say I have it should I look at
the car his car and I see this thing you
know I took I take and I just put my
chest here and I just go boom yes crazy
but everything is good now and
everything there the guys save it and
you know I hope one day I want to see
him again you know hear that the parents
do everybody just say say something to
the guys yes did you see the
no no no no no yet I want to see you
know I want one day one day for sure
happen
what you do after you got out of there I
just take my stuff go to my home you
know I just went home
yes all day all day this is my mind you
know I have to smoke after that just
relax you know yeah just go to my home
and I think this think I have a my
daughter's shoe save it you know because
you want your daddy is a different
feeling you know for sure assessment is
different different thing when you you
know the situation it's like a extremist
situation you know yeah yes but want you
to go to the fight you know this you
know for sure a lot of the adrenaline
but this time I feel in my heart both
hey Michael go in my mouth and I come
back my heart you know crazy Mike you
ever been in any situation like that but
you go for shorty you go I think a lot
of guys go mean is it's very hard
situation when do you sort this
situation and then the kids there for
sure you go men you know you swim you
know so unfortunate nobody will swim you
very actively the guy's human you for
sure you run into the you have safety
guys I believe that you yeah well I
think you just jumped into action
you know those life and death search
situations
yeah yeah so you got your fight coming
up stuff about that yeah yeah this is
give me a lot of motivation for the
fight yeah I don't know why but they
gave me you know yeah but this dude
hasn't saved somebody's life
no wedge on him yeah yes and yes they
fight very very good fight you know
because the Gordon Ryan is a good
grappling he's the best in the world now
he just the wind he got the World
Championship no grappling fights but his
lap the bitch-slap is there
and a mic everything is changed when
they'll grab with somebody and the guy
slap your face it's different you know
so no punching but no question just lap
just handle open the hand and the
bangbang you know no no don't cut it
they like it no karate not just like you
know this part here and I think it is
you know there's a knock you out yes yes
yes yeah I mean I'm excited for this
fight combat called combat ug to the new
oh how much you jeez
yes I want to go please is he a massage
will please where's that is I I don't
know the place but they I like to know
guys the place you know yes
yeah please let us invite Rob chew when
I rub their I wanna I know you know Rob
will be there yeah for sure
well thanks ma'am British amen thank for
you guys anything you want to shout out
while you're here no I'm yeah sure got
nothing hey anytime brother anytime
we're here we'd love to have you all
British a man thank nice thanks man
Thank You mo the hero Fabricio Werdum
we're out
[Music]